muhammad did i read an article recently  though that that you have most of your  money in cash is that right so so what  I've done is I've barbell my exposure if  you ask the question what's the most  expensive part of the markets it's where  everybody has been pushed into by  central banks that's the most heavily  trafficked part of the market it is the  public market it is public equities and  public bonds so in reaction to that  people including me have been bar  belling taking some of that exposure  back into cash and then taking some of  that exposure into higher risk less  liquid less public exposures where it's  harder it's harder for such the central  bank to push people in so think of it as  bar belling in order to minimize  exposures to the part of the market that  is most heavily trafficked because of  central banks